Bonjour à tous! Aujourd'hui je suis à Ubisoft, on va me présenter un jeu vidéo que je vais avoir la chance de pouvoir doubler avec ma bouche.
J'ai juste trop hâte, c'est parti !
Ton personnage c'est un youtubeur, hyper sportif, super enthousiaste qui gueule tout le temps.
DAMN les gens, la petite dinde !
Ce petit personnage s'appelle Levi et c'est celui que je double.
Il faut savoir quil a 16 ans
Bon bah écoute ils ont choisi quelqu'un de mature pour le...pour le rôle. Ils ont pensé à moi tout de suite.
Par contre il faut arrêter de m’appeler Norman maintenant c'est Levi !
Let's go! Et voilà ce qui se passe avec Leviiiii
baaaby!
Hey ! T'as l'air cool ! Tu veux rejoindre notre équipe? On sait pas ce qui nous attend.
Bah je vais te dire un truc qui s'y trouve moi, une réunion de robots super méchants !
[En anglais]
Dude, that's awesome ! An other alien bro, for the win !
C'est trop cool mec ! On a un nouveau pote alien pour nous aider! Wouah ça va très vite l'enchainement, putain...j'ai pas le temps de respirer.
Levi, c'est toi? Ah mais ouais! Ce crash était carrément pété quoi. Allez
là je sais pas si t'as vu, mais j'ai genre tout défoncé! Bonjour j'articule très très peu, embauchez moi! Boumm...merde...putain
Attends c'est dur. Essaie de prendre ton temps un peu plus sur le tout.
Boumm.. Ça va être trop trop bien ! Bienvenue dans l'équipe ! Bien joué, bien joué. Qu'est ce que t'en dis hein?
Hein Matiot. Alors tout va bien, c'est très sympa à faire le problème c'est que j'arrête pas de
saturer ma voix parce que je dois crier et porter la voix et du coup je suis en train de me la défoncer.
Yan va m'annoncer le chiffre, le nombre de phrases que j'ai à dire en tout. Il a pas voulu me le dire jusqu'à présent.
Il te reste 225 répliques.
Ahahah!
Allez, bim !
Mais attends, mais on s'en fout puisqu'on fait l'un des plus beaux métiers du monde! La comédie française !
Yes! On n'a pas à se plaindre, c'est le meilleur métier du monde.
Allez, action !
Eh!Je crois que cette flèche réagit à mon arme! Je me demande ce qui se passerait si j'en essayais une autre...Le mec dit vraiment tout, quoi !
Il faut que tu tires avec ta mannette sur son point faible
maintenant. Mais j'en fais des caisses quand je parle ! Je pars d'en bas et je monte en haut!
Waouh ! Elle est ouf cette tempête ! J'ai trop envie de foncer dedans ! Braaah ! C'est qui le patron? C'est Levi le patron !
Wouhouhou, je vais kiffer!
Wouhouhou, je vais kiffer !
J'ai plus de voix ,j'ai juste trop mal aux cordes vocales quoi...
Yes! Fin de journée ! Première fois que j'enregistre de l'animation et bon bah super expérience.
J'ai juste hâte de faire la deuxième journée qui est dans quelques jours. D'ici là, je vais prendre pas mal de...de miel.
Là l'équipe d'Ubisoft va me présenter le jeu en avant premierre
C'est parti. Donc en fait, c'est pas qu'un simple jeu vidéo, tu rajoutes aussi des petits jouets sur la manette. Exactement,
ça s'appelle des jouets modulaires. Donc, quand tu plug le vaisseau sur la manette, ça se répercute directement dans le jeu ?
C'est génial ! Tu as également la même chose avec les armes.
Je pense que là on va partir sur une petite mitraillette. Donc là, je plug une arme qui va directement se répercuter dans le jeu.
I did it ! Donc ça, c'est mon personnage qui s'appelle Levi comme
Marc Levy. Yes, Marc Levy. Donc toi, tu te casses.
Et tu laisse place au king. WAOUW! Un alien ! Ohohoh wou !
Donc y'a tous ces vaisseaux.On peut jouer avec tout ça. Enfait, c'est l'un des plus puissants, il a été construit avec un moteur v6 en
fait, y'a pas mieux quoi. Donc quand tu connais un petit peu les vaisseaux spaciaux...Après on a ça, plus basé sur un moteur Tesla.
C'est-à-dire qui marche à l'énergie renouvelable.
Bon, c'est plus un vaisseau de babos, on va pas se mentir. Et donc lui, c'est le vaisseau Nadir, hein. Donc
un nom un peu plus oriental qui donc a un vaisseau arbie , qui expulse de la fumée de chicha. Blague raciste merci.
Allez. Norman, on a préparé un petit quelque chose pour toi. Oh noon !
Ça tue ! C'est le pull de Levi quoi ! En tout cas, deuxième journée d'enregistrement en studio. Cette fois-ci, encore plus que d'habitude, la patate !
On a beaucoup de phrases à enregistrer. Sans plus attendre,
on part en cabine. Et aujourd'hui, on va voir si ma voix s'en porte mieux. Lalolilolu
Bienvenue dans l'atlas !
Waouh ! Je vais faire un max de vues avec ma story ! Hors de question. Levi, personne n'est censé être au courant...
Il est temps que ça change !
Attends là, mais tu délires ! C'est bien, c'est bien parfait. En fait, c'est juste un gros ballon peteur quoi ! [Bruit de pet] Merci madame !
Ce qui est bien, c'est que ça met bien en valeur en tout cas mon humour. C'est cool...
J'ai l'impression d'avoir le nez dans un homme qui a mauvaise haleine pendant tout l'après-midi, qui me ferait [souffle].
L'un de nous, il a dit ! Ahahah
Let's go,big pote. Ça devrait déjà nous suffire pour décoller. Ouais, ou pour être vaporisé totalement !
[Immitation de bruit d'explosion]
[Norman fait différentes onomatopées]
On est avec Skyyart, qui est aussi ingé' son à ses heures perdues.
Pas que pro gamer ! Cet homme ressemble beaucoup trop à Skyyart, attention. Yo, je suis Levi McRay et je viens
massacrer la légion ! Est-ce que je peux faire quelque chose pour me rendre utile ?
Merci Norman, c'était vraiment parfait, bien joué !
Putain de merde...
[En anglais]
Oh, that's lame !
Mesdames et messieurs, nous enregistrons le dernier fichier.
Bon, globalement, on a enregistré 500 phrases pour ce jeu et là on est sur la toute dernière phrase qui est plutôt un cri.
C'est un cri de chute.
OK, on prépare le miel et la tisane.
Ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Yes, on a fini !
C'était juste trop bien !
Bravo tout le monde !
Merci Skyyart !
-Ces 2 jours étaient incroyables.
-Merci, bravo.
On a réussi à combattre la galaxie .
En tous cas, je suis très content de cette expérience de doublage.
Pas évident, mais voilà. J'ai appris plein de trucs, ça a été très enrichissant.
Le personnage de Levi, vraiment je le kiffe parce qu'il est vraiment haut en couleur .
J'ai déjà eu la chance de doubler le personnage principal du film Projet X, il y a quelques années.
C'était génial, mais aussi sur un film plus classique faut vraiment suivre ce qu'a fait déjà le personnage, marcher dans son sillon
et coller à toutes ses onomatopées. Alors que dans un film d'animation ou dans un jeu vidéo,
la liberté de création est beaucoup plus ample. On peut se permettre de faire plus d'impro,
plus de montagnes russes et de se lâcher en fait. Ça c'est très cool.
Du coup, juste moi, je kiffe. J'ai pris du plaisir à faire ça et j'espère que vous avez pris un petit peu plaisir aussi à
regarder cette vidéo. N'hésitez pas à mettre un petit thumb to the top !
Je vous laisse là dessus et moi je retourne dans mon vaisseau parce que j'ai un maximum de sasquid à exterminer
afin de sauver la galaxie !
Levi McCray débarque !